[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
who's your best friend Ben okay but okay
but what do you mean what happens when
there's no pie left I don't think the
fact that I work with him invalidates
the Friendship Ben is truly the only
thing I care about on earth when none of
you knew who I was and didn't really
care Ben thought I was really funny Ben
is is my brother and best friend I mean
Ben is the only person really in my life
that I know will stay there forever
because we built the things we've done
well I've made a lot of money but you
look at your life and you go oh I wish I
had more relationships with people that
I've let fall by the wayside
[Music]
I still don't
agree I'm not apologizing you're acting
like you're a victim of talking about
the thing you chose to talk I'm not a
victim at all it hurts me more than it
hurts you today's Tuesday October 11th
and the Tim Dillon show officially has
their new producer as of last week Owen
Roeder from Barstool Sports has stepped
into the role held many years by Ben
Avery welcome back to the joke World
comedy update every single Monday bring
you all the news you need to know from
your favorite podcast your favorite
comedians anything and everything
happening with the comedy world all in
one place every week so make sure you
subscribe to joke world right now if you
already haven't download this episode on
Spotify to support the show and go
follow us on Instagram if you send us a
DM we'll send you some free stickers
right back I got offered something else
I think I have to try and I'm gonna be
doing that do you want to see what
you're doing
uh sure uh I'll be producing the Tim
Dillon show moving forward which is kind
of kind of fire kind of huge yeah that's
kind of yeah it's huge I just can't say
no and uh hopefully helping him work on
some bigger projects moving forward and
stuff like that somehow it's only been
eight days since Ben Avery announced
he's leaving the Tim Dillon show and
actually a lot has happened in the past
week at first it seemed like a mutual
parting of ways that Ben was moving on
to do other projects and Tim was fully
supporting him but in the last week
there seems to be more negativity
surrounding the situation most of this
negativity stems from the patreon
episode that was released right after
Ben resigned Rey comp was a guest and he
started off the episode by shooting on
Ben pretty hard Tim was kind of going
along with it just trying to make light
of the whole situation as he does he
doesn't want to be a giggler I gotta
respect that you know I receive stay
tuned for the next Ben Avery project
whatever it is I mean God bless him and
I I you know it's not over money so I do
feel like he I said hey here's a
shitload of money yeah do something you
don't love to do anymore and because for
me I go do it take the money right but
for him he has this Morality In This
code where he's like I don't want to use
you for money I'm not happy and I you
know maybe I created a hostile work
environment with you know and I'd say
shut up to him on the show I didn't mean
shut up I meant I don't want you to talk
but it's a bit you made like a hostile
work environment about like creating a
show that was usually successful and
yeah paying him tons of money yes it's
very hostile it is bad yeah much like in
my opinion much like Jimmy Fallon
there'll always be a place in the
business for Ben Avery he'll land on his
feet that I think he will and I am going
to do my thing it's still going to be a
solo show we're bringing in new
producers to hired a new guy yeah who's
really good the show needed a little bit
of reinvention right because it was
getting stale and Ben I think quit two
years ago but he kept coming in and that
I respect look I mean I kept hearing
about like new ideas that were coming
new like you know new projects and I was
very excited and uh one day maybe I'll
I'll see him you know whatever but no it
seemed like Tim realized the episode
didn't come off that great that people
weren't ready to make light of the
situation or they were surprised that he
was already joking around about it and
going kind of hard at Ben so the episode
was pulled down pretty shortly after it
was uploaded and then Tim posted this
explanation I wanted to let everybody
know why we took down the patreon
episode that we had just put out
um when I came on the patreon I felt the
best way to do it with you guys was to
be
funny about it because the show the Tim
Dylan show has always been like a funny
show we've never really been serious on
the show that's not what we do we say
crazy [ __ ] all the time about everybody
and that's what we do that's kind of the
that's why you guys like the show it's
why we have hundreds of thousands of
people listening to the show
um but you know when we listen to the
episode back
um it felt callous and cold and I love
Ben and I didn't want Ben to be hurt by
the episode which I think he was
probably hurt by it
um it was not my intention all I wanted
was to break the news in kind of a funny
way
um that's how I handle everything that
matters in my life I've never been good
at being serious I'm rarely serious uh
you know you guys know me well enough to
know that like everything in my life for
my schizophrenic mother to to my family
issues
it's all public and I deal with it 100
with hobby which is not good it
definitely makes sense why people were
mad but at the same time as a Tim Dillon
fan how else do you expect him to react
you know he makes light of every
situation in the world whether it be
serious or not he tries to make it funny
he tries to make fun of it but this one
definitely pissed off the fans some
people are calling it the end of the
show some people are saying that
everyone has some Mass unsubscribe even
the most recent episode with Greg Stone
all the comments are about missing Ben
that Ben's ruining the show by not being
on it now and the like to dislike ratio
is pretty insane actually 6.3
000 likes and 5.3 000 dislikes as of
October 8th so only a thousand more
likes and dislikes the fans are
definitely showing their frustration
with how this whole band thing was
handled or the fact that he's just not
on the show anymore altogether the new
producer Owen Roeder comes over from
Barstool Sports he was involved with the
yak and Son of a boy dad two shows I
personally really enjoy so I have high
expectations I think he'll do great in
the role he said he's been working with
Tim cutting up Clips Distributing things
for a few weeks now which means that he
was already in place hired before Ben's
announcement this is wasn't like
expected or plotted I was you didn't
apply no I had been I had met him once
and I you met him a couple times yeah
and then got invited oh yeah yeah yeah
and I was pitching him my pipe dream was
I had been writing a mockumentary
working to put all your guys sketches in
one place and I was hoping to like cast
him as like a small part I don't know
it all happened it was very funny
because we were about to record son of a
boy dad and Owen was like I gotta call
Tim Dillon and I come in he's like do
you have like any ideas or anything you
want me to tell him it was just like the
complete opposite of what we expected
the call to be yeah yeah so it seems
like Owen will do a good job and as a
fan of the Tim Dillon show myself I
appreciate Tim going out and finding
someone that looks exactly like Ben
today is day 11 of sober October for Joe
Rogan Tom segora Bert Kreischer and Ari
shaffir and the whole gang was able to
get together three days ago to record a
podcast so like women are like [ __ ]
high-end IPOs like out the gate right
and men are penny stocks and then they
invest like like they they kind of like
like a hedge fund they look at these
penny stocks like you were a hardcore
penny stock but you were I remember you
were gaining weight and you were [ __ ]
like you were like and your materials
questionables
but I know I've known him so long that
when when Christina signed up for him
that was a that was a risky investment
it was this year's sober October
challenge is to stay completely sober
the whole month obviously do 100
push-ups a day and do one workout a day
that burns at least 500 calories the
episode that they record is hilarious I
definitely go listen to that right now
it seems like Ari's having the hardest
time with the physical aspect of it
especially the 100 push-ups part and
surprisingly Joe is having the hardest
time with the sobriety aspect of it he
says he's missing weed this time more
than ever also at the very end of the
episode Tom and Bert gave Joe and Ari
permission to eat an edible that night
they were going to a Roger Waters
concert and they were complaining that
they had to be sober during it that it
was only right that they could get some
sort of Buzz Joe was joking that he was
going to Huff paint before the show and
hold his breath just to get literally
any buzz and Tom and Bert said yuck full
transparency if you eat an edible you
eat an edible no one is confirmed or
denied that this happened but we did get
this pretty cool picture from the night
Bobby Kelly's new special kill box
premiered three days ago on Louis ck.com
he's been making the podcast rounds this
week so far appearing on flagrant
skeptic tank Chrissy chaos taste buds
and are you garbage you came in with a
certain jacket or a hat I remember
Patrice came in he looked like he sold
his own barbecue sauce
I mean Billy Burr one night one of the
greatest smashings ever was when he was
doing comedy on a bus to get World
Series tickets like a tour bus no on a
bus to Yankee Stadium so he would jump
on the bus and they'd do stand up and
then some people in the movie
Louis C.K directed the special it's
available on his website right now for
just ten dollars and you get access to
it for a full five years guest spots
from last week your mom's house talked
to Matt brogner two bears one cave was
Tom and Greg Fitzsimmons whiskey Ginger
had on Girls Gotta Eat Greg Stone was on
the Tim Dylan show flagrant had on Bobby
Kelly like we mentioned and kill Tony
was Dave Attell breckfit Simmons and Ian
fightans you're out there delivering
mail all around the city have you ever
heard of the East Austin comedy club
before
[Applause]
not once you ever get one you ever get
bit by any dogs not yet not yet but but
some have attacked uh the chihuahuas
chase you they do okay all right enough
about the Mexican ladies in the city
theovan and this past weekend talked
with Scott staff this week the Honeydew
had on John fidelberg from Barstool The
Joe Rogan Experience with the whole
sober October crew like we already
mentioned and we might be drunk out on
Daniel sloths as far as new specials go
there's two recent uploads to Netflix
Nick Kroll's Little Big Boy and Hassan
Minaj the king's Jester I watched this
one with my roommate it's very funny and
it's also kind of different the setting
is cool he has a little PowerPoint
behind him so he's putting up images and
other videos during his presentation
according to the description the comic
brings his signature style to the
stories about sucking snot out of his
daughter's nose meeting Saudi officials
and becoming famous and then of course
Robert Kelly kill box is out now as well
on Louis ck.com that's it for this
episode The Joke World comedy update
thank you so much for watching please
make sure to subscribe if you haven't
already follow us on Instagram it's
definitely worth it we're posting
similar content on our Instagram really
trying to build that up please go follow
us on Instagram and download this
episode on Spotify or wherever you
listen to podcasts to support our show
downloads are really the only metric
that matters so if you want to get this
bigger and push it out download it if
you want it to get smaller if you want
the show to get smaller
then don't do anything that I just said
but that would be rude
I think this is a good idea for comedy
okay thank you for watching we'll see
you next Monday
[Music]